[Musik]
so sieht er aus der neue boris boris der
im könig jeden tag in einem neuen
medizinischen outfit interessiert
engagiert aufmunternd tourt der premier
durch die labore test und im zentrum des
landes
keine gelegenheit lässt er aus um sich
zu zeigen an der spitze des britischen
pfundes die hoffnung die sich in
großbritannien breitmacht nach einem
jahr der traurigkeit ist auch die
geschichte der schottischen
krankenschwester maria ihr mann war der
erste polizist der in schottland
ankowitsch starb das war im mai
es war völlig unerwartet so ein schock
erschienen sich so gut zu erholen
und ich habe immer zu ihm gesagt wird
john lass mich nicht allein
und dann hat corona ihn gepackt und er
ist gestorben
nun behandelt maria nicht nur kurve
patienten sie impft auch john hätte
gewollt dass ich weitermache er wollte
dass man anderen hilft er wäre froh dass
ich das tue auch wenn ich noch trauere
anderen nun hoffnung zu geben ist etwas
das ihr selbst hilft überall im land
kommt der impfstoff als trost nach dem
des vergangenen jahres
[Gelächter]
meine frau ist im märz gestorben es war
ganz ganz furchtbar
verzeihen sie ich fang nicht gleich
wieder und dann musste ich mich mit
einer lungenentzündung missionieren
so viele menschen haben so viel verloren
so viele menschen trauern
mir bedeutet dass sehr viel ich hoffe
dass ich sobald alle geimpft sind meine
enkel wieder sehen kann
mit jedem geimpften briten scheint auch
der premier wieder an lebendigkeit zu
gewinnen
im herbst schlug die britische variante
mit aller macht zu die zahlen schnellen
wieder in die höhe über routen die der
ersten welle die fast einhellige kritik
lautete boris johnson handelt wie schon
das ganze jahr 2020 über zu spät und zu
unentschieden
[Musik]
es lief überhaupt nicht gut für ihn
nichts funktionierte wir hatten und
haben die schlimmsten todeszahlen in
europa wir waren nicht in der lage
schutzkleidung zu besorgen
der allgemeine eindruck war der von
chaos und inkompetenz bis der impfstoff
kam
und den hat das land kate bingen zu
verdanken der premiere nennt sie im mai
zur vorsitzenden der britischen impft
task force ein genialer schachzug urteil
johnstons biograf tom bauer hält dinge
misst eine risikokapital anleger raus
sie wusste wie man impfstoffe besorgt
mit einer konkurrenzfähigen preis
strategien
sie ist selbst biochemikerin hat
impfexperte um sich geschart die
richtigen leute gefunden und die
bürokratie ausgetrickst
sie hat die normalen regierungs wegen
ignoriert das war das geheimnis ihres
erfolgs als im juni die
eu-gesundheitsminister die kommission
damit beauftragen den ankauf von
impfstoffen zu koordinieren hat kate
dinge längst eingekauft
großbritannien steht jetzt gut da weil
unser team aus dem privaten sektor die
branche sehr gut kennt wir haben die
impf landschaft schnell analysiert und
waren dann die ersten die mit oxford
erst für senica und kaiser bei und tech
verträge gemacht haben
dank dieser risikofreude sieht der bis
dato glücklose premier nun aus wie der
der zuletzt lacht großbritannien impft
wie ein weltmeister 1000 pixar pro
minute jeder vierte erwachsene hat die
erste dosis bekommen auch weil
großbritannien als einziges land
entschieden hat die zweitimpfung erst
nach zwölf statt der empfohlenen drei
wochen zu verabreichen
der imf erfolg scheint der idee des brh
exit wir sind besser dran ohne die
recht zu geben was die praxis anhänger
immer gesagt haben war die eu ist eine
schwerfällige bürokratie wie unfähig ist
auch die bedürfnisse ihrer mitglieder
einzugehen und die probleme bei der
impfstoffversorgung in der eu spielen
genau dieser kritik in die hände
mit dem sich füllenden info meter auf
seinem twitter-account steigen auch die
zustimmungswerte für den premier wieder
nicht so sehr allerdings in den drei
nationen nordirland wales und schottland
der praxis und das kogit management
haben die zweifel an der union mit
england überall wachsen lassen
vergangene woche gesucht johnson deshalb
schottland er will den nationalisten
einimpfen ohne die regierung in london
stünde tier jetzt schlechter da hinzu
kommen die gravierenden probleme durch
den dreck cit von denen mitten in der
imf euphorie aus sicht des premiers
angenehm selten gesprochen wird
die strukturellen schwierigkeiten
bleiben doch johnson nimmt einen neuen
anlauf
er hat sich verändert erstens weil er
krank war
er hat dem tod ins auge geblickt
außerdem hat er sich unter dem druck der
regierungsverantwortung verändert als er
noch außenminister war hat er steinmeier
ihn verabscheut angela merkel auf sie
fanden er benahm sich wie ein clown
aber er ist gereift seine stärke ist das
erlernen kann
und wir erleben jetzt einen anderen
boris johnson was die zukunft bringt wer
weiß es schon eine immunsystem variante
könnte den vorsprung der briten zu
nichte machen die folgen der pandemie
für wirtschaft und gesundheitssystem
werden verheerend sein ist rot das
auseinanderbrechen des königreichs doch
noch schweigt in london ein premier in
seinem erfolg und trägt stolz die im
zahlen vor
[Musik]